momento de hablar de economía quién
france24 me acompaña en el estudio
daniel hablando con daniela muy buenas
noches comenzamos en chile- semana
decisiva para las pensiones en ese país
si santiago muy buenas noches en julio
recordemos se aprobó un primer retiro
del 10 por ciento y la gran mayoría de
los afiliados aprovechó y sacó parte de
su ahorro pensional ahora se está
discutiendo el retiro de otro 10% pero
no sólo es uno sino todos los proyectos
que se analizarán el jueves en el senado
uno de los diputados de oposición y otro
del gobierno que siempre se ha opuesto
que los ciudadanos se gasten sus fondos
previsionales antes de tiempo el de la
oposición va más adelantado ya pasó la
prueba en cámara de diputados y espera
debate en plenaria el del oficialismo
apenas pasó su primer trámite en
comisiones en un principio ambas
iniciativas eran muy distintas pero ya
están casi iguales las dos por ejemplo
prevé en un retiro mínimo de un millón
de pesos chilenos y un máximo de 43
millones pero veamos también las
diferencias santiago que son pocas
el oficialismo busca agravar el retiro
entregar el dinero en dos cuotas y
excluir a las altas autoridades de este
beneficio y su contraparte propone una
sola cuota y que cualquier persona
retire sin pagar impuestos hablemos
ahora de venezuela porque el gobierno de
ese país busca soluciones a la fuerte
devaluación que está presentando la
moneda local la vicepresidenta y
ministra de economía del cis rodríguez
anunció un conjunto de medidas para
reanimar la moneda nacional que es el
bolívar que ha sufrido una fuerte
devaluación mire de santiago hace un año
un dólar costaba 35 mil bolívares hoy
cuesta 26 veces más más de 900 mil
bolívares apenas en un mes la tasa de
cambio se ha duplicado todo esto en el
mercado oficial porque el paralelo
sabemos que tiene unos valores
absolutamente distintos entre las
medidas anunciadas están por ejemplo la
ampliación del límite de transferencias
bancarias digitales que hoy están 100
millones de bolívares o sea a 100
dólares también subirá el tope
pagos diarios con tarjeta débito y habrá
más impuestos a las transacciones
bancarias que se hagan en divisas entre
otras medidas nos vamos ahora hasta
francia porque allí cobrarán una tasa
digital a las grandes multinacionales
este año santiago se trata de un
impuesto del 3% previsto para las
grandes corporaciones digitales que
facturen anualmente más de 750 millones
de euros en el mundo y 25 millones en
francia como por ejemplo amazon google
facebook y apoya el tema viene siendo
discutido con pocos avances a la luz de
la ocde pero como no hubo un acuerdo
francia ya envió la liquidación de 2020
y lo hizo a pesar de las advertencias de
administración de donald trump de
responder con aranceles a productos
franceses como por ejemplo los bolsos de
cuero o los cosméticos hablemos ahora de
méxico que enfrenta una dura pelea con
la comisión europea en bruselas nada más
y nada menos que por el tequila le voy a
contar la historia santiago mire hoy en
día hay una disputa legal en la comisión
europea entre la cervecería de países
heineken y el consejo regulador del
tequila de méxico esto por el uso de la
denominación de origen del tequila en
una de sus cervezas el producto en
disputa se llama desesperados una
cerveza con aroma a tequila que se
comercializa en 70 países y en méxico
están muy disgustados porque el tequila
solo se puede producir con ese nombre en
la ciudad del mismo nombre que queda en
jalisco el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador dice que tomará acciones
contundentes para proteger esa
denominación de origen en el continente
que consume anualmente 20 millones de
litros indicadores de la jornada como el
es para los principales parques en el
mundo hubo pocas negociaciones en wall
street en la víspera del festivo de
acción de gracias' y sus índices
cerraron mixtos las bolsas europeas
cerraron dispares y con movimientos muy
leves esto después de una eufórica
jornada anterior y en latinoamérica
brasilia encadena su tercera jornada
consecutiva al alza cifra del día para
el cierre daniela
cuando son los 1200 millones de dólares
al año que en promedio pierde cada país
de américa latina por el embarazo
adolescente que es una de las
principales consecuencias de la
desprotección a la que se ven sometidas
las mujeres es a propósito de que este
miércoles se con este jueves se
conmemora el día internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer muchas gracias daniela por este
reporte del mundo económico gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía sigan en france
24 buenas noches
[Música]